- I can't speak for
every state in the union
about exactly what their
voting rights and laws are.
But there are things in
that bill that are mandated
that Florida already does.
We already have
early voting here.
We have a 14-day period or
13-day period of early voting.
And then you've got, anybody
can vote by mail in Florida.
You don't have to prove
that you're gonna be
out of town or whatever.
And then you've
got election day,
where you can go
to your precinct
and from 7:00 am to 7:00 pm,
as long as you're in
line before 7:00 pm,
you can vote that way.
So it's never been easier.
But when I first ran
for office in 2010,
there was still, you know,
early voting was at one point
in the state limited,
it didn't even exist
20 years ago, right.
Then when I first voted
in my first election 1989,
there was no early voting.
If you wanted to vote absentee,
you had to write a letter
saying I'm gonna be out of town
or having surgery or
whatever it is on that day.
And so, I just think
it's ever been easier
to either register or
to vote in Florida.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin.
This is the Rubin report
with my first interview,
from the free state of Florida.
And we got the right guy for it,
Florida Senator Marco Rubio.
Senator, how are you?
- I'm good.
Glad to have you here.
And just a disclaimer
at the outset.
This is like real
world right here.
I'm in my backyard.
I got my dog is right here, so
if you hear a little barking,
that's why I'm using these,
but, we're not trying
to stage anything here.
It's all real man.
- There is...
- So, I apologize
ahead if he barks.
- You're going
full Florida, man.
So first off
(Marco chuckles)
as you know,
I just moved here from the
crazy state of California.
I've been here for
a couple of weeks,
just moved into the house.
I'm in my makeshift studio.
Now, you are nice enough to do
a little promo video for me,
welcoming me here.
So let's just start with
the state of Florida first.
I mean, what is it about Florida
that sorta like allowed Florida
to do it right over
these last two years?
Like, I don't think it's
just the political part,
although that's a part of it.
What is it about just
sort of the Florida man,
the Florida woman
- Yeah.
- That did something right here.
- That's a great question.
I do think it starts with
political leadership,
but maybe the truth is that
that the people produce
that political leadership.
They reward a certain
kind of leadership
and don't reward others.
But, you know, I think the
key thing about Florida
and understand is
that everyone's
from somewhere else
for the most part.
And that means another
part of the country
like you are married.
Hundreds of thousands
of people in Florida
that have done what you've done.
And that is you came
here because you
didn't like what life
was like under the leadership
of people in some other state.
And so, when people come
to a place to get away
from that kind of stuff
there, they came for a reason.
So I think that's
a big part of it.
And it's not just
from other states.
We also have people that
come from other countries.
So here in south Florida,
as I'm sure you've
already experienced,
we have a lot of people that
obviously came from Cuba
or their parents did and then
Venezuela and then Nicaragua.
And so any time that there is,
or for that matter, you know,
any time there's any sort
of a left-wing disruption
to Latin America.
So for example, Peru elected
a president who was far left
and even anti-American,
and suddenly you see the
real estate purchases
from Peruvian skyrocket.
People come here to get
away from that stuff.
They come here from
other countries,
they come here from other states
and I think that's
a big, big part
of what makes
Florida what it is.
And it's something we really
need to protect, you know.
And it's a dynamic
state in many ways,
it's sort of a 21st century
frontier state in that way.
- Well listen man, I
am here to protect it.
As I keep telling people,
(Marco chuckles)
I'm here to keep
Florida, Florida.
I have noticed, you know,
you mentioned the
international part of this.
I mean, one thing I've
definitely noticed
in a couple of weeks here,
especially in the
Miami area, I mean,
everyone brings their
own driving customs here.
There is a certain set
(Marco chuckles)
of ways that you
drive in Florida
that I have not seen
in California before.
- Yeah.
I mean, it's always the
game about, you know,
can I beat the red light
or is it, you know,
it's all like a ten second rule
on the red light, you know,
like the light is red, but
does it really mean red?
(Dave chuckles)
Or do I get, it's
something like,
you can drop something
on the floor,
you get a two second
rule, whatever.
Same thing with that, you know,
everybody's trying
to figure out how
to use a Backstreet to
cut-through traffic.
There's a little bit
of that, you know,
and it's part of the
flare of the place.
I'm not encouraging
people to do it,
but it's part of the, sort
of the character of it.
I think that's true
would probably more
in south Florida than in
other parts of the state,
but it is, yeah I
know it's different.
- I've definitely become a bit
(Marco chuckles)
of a Venezuelan or
Cuban driver already
in a couple of weeks here.
But in these last two years,
that Florida
continued to flourish
while so many states collapsed.
And as you said, there are
quite literally hundreds
of thousands of people moving
in this direction right now.
What do you do to stop
people who made the mistakes
in the blue states from
repeating those mistakes here?
I'm not going to
repeat those mistakes,
but, you know, obviously
some people will.
- Yeah.
I think first of all, it's,
self-selected, I mean,
you know, I'm not saying
that's true for everybody,
but frankly, the
bottom line is this,
if you live in California and
you watch MSNBC habitually
and you spend all
day on Twitter,
you think that in
Florida we have bodies
all over the streets
and we have, you know,
people are just
dying left and right.
And Governor DeSantis is
the leader of a death cult.
So you're not kind
of moved to Florida,
if that's what you think,
unless your job makes
you or something.
So by and large people
that are moving here
are people that are,
they don't believe that
stuff when they come.
Now, doesn't mean that's
true for everybody.
And look, well this is a
state with diverse opinions,
but this has always been a
state that's had liberals.
This has always been a
state that's had people
that are left of center
on their political views,
but I don't think that's
the dividing line anymore.
I mean, I think you can be
a liberal and not be crazy.
I think what we're talking
about now is things
that go well beyond
just traditional,
I want higher taxes
and more government.
This is the complete
total abandonment
of common sense, of
balance of the reason
and almost so hysteria and its
approach to different issues.
And I do think we've avoided
a lot of that happening here.
It doesn't mean it's
not present at all,
but I don't see a
of that happening,
it doesn't mean, you know,
that there aren't people
that hold those views
or they talk in those ways,
but I think what's
really important is
to show the results, right.
At the end of the day,
there's a reason
why Ocasio-Cortez
and, you know, all
these other members
of Congress come
down here to vacation
and party on New Year's Eve.
And it's because, you know,
they may be in favor of the
rules or they at least publicly
in favor of the rules
and their home state.
But when it comes time
to actually enjoy life,
they're coming here,
they're not going to some
of these other places.
And so, I think
reminding people that,
and comparing us to
all these other states
and what they're
going through is one
of the most important things
we can continue to do to,
to convince people
and win this battle.
- Do you ever envy the fact
that the Democrats can get away
with virtually anything,
like AOC can be partying
down here at clubs, you know,
maskless and the whole thing
while she's locking
down her own people
when clearly, if you
were to do anything
that the media could figure out
in some slight way
was hypocritical,
or when say, Senator
Cruz went on a vacation
that was long planned for a
couple of days, they go bananas,
but Democrats can
pretty much do anything.
Do you ever get a
little jealous of that?
- You know, that's
a great question.
And let me tell
you what happens.
And I can talk to you about
my evolution on all of this.
I think when you first kind of
get into politics, you know,
I got to like the 10
years ago and I get there
and I'm new to the
place and all that.
And so, whether it's
the people around you
or just your own instincts,
you sorta think you all
right, you guys, yes,
they're left of center
and they're liberal,
but at some point there's
some fairness in them, right.
And so, I think you
waste a lot of time
thinking you're going to impress
people in the legacy media.
And I think that's worse
than it's ever been
in terms of their
bias and so forth.
And I think maybe
one of the things
that Donald Trump revealed
is you're never gonna
impress these people.
I mean, they're never
gonna treat you the same
as they do the other side.
I think once you abandon that,
and once you accept
that that's a fact.
And then the next step
is realizing by the way,
a lot of people notice,
like there's a lot
of people out there
that notice this
double standard.
And so I always chuckle
about things like,
for example, you know,
look, I ran for president,
I finished in third place
in the delegate count,
I made it all the
way to Florida,
It didn't turn out the
way I wanted it to,
but that was God's plan
for our country and for my life.
And I, you know, there are a
lot of things I've been able
to do over the last four years.
I wouldn't have been able to do
if I had won that race or
never been the nominee.
And, you know, they call
me up for a long time,
They wrote about Marco Rubio,
failed presidential candidate.
You know, Kamala
Harris didn't even
make it out of California.
(Dave chuckles)
She didn't even
make it to December
- Polled it zero,
polled it zero.
- Yeah, Cory Booker didn't
even make it to December.
He didn't even make
it to the first stage
and they're called former
presidential candidates.
So I'm a failed one,
they're a former one.
I don't care, but
it's an example
of that sort of double
standard and it exists.
And I think there comes a point
where you kind of
realize, who cares,
like it doesn't really matter.
People see it.
And frankly, people
don't believe it anymore.
We're just not
living in an era now.
There're more people that
will watch this podcast
then we'll read, you know,
what the local newspaper writes
about me on any given day.
And once you sort
of realize that,
it makes life a lot
easier, you know.
- Yeah, you know, so with
some of the COVID stuff here,
because to your point,
if you watch MSNBC,
they may, or read
the New York times,
they make it sound like
everyone's dying in Florida.
I'll tell you a
very straight up,
I got COVID right when I got
here, my whole staff got COVID.
I was able to get
monoclonal treatment.
It took literally about an hour.
I was able to get ivermectin.
I was sick for a couple of
days, and then I was better.
It was just fine.
That's not to say that
COVID doesn't exist here,
of course it does.
But that's in stark contrast
to a place like California
or New York where you can't
really get those treatments.
I mean, first off, they want
you to have a positive test
to get the treatment,
but then you can't
even get the test.
So when you guys were
putting together the policy
on all of this, and
when you were talking
to the governor and the
other health officials,
how much pressure
did you feel to like,
we don't want to
be the one state
that is a little
more open, but then,
we end up being the one
that really screws it up?
- Well look, I mean,
there's a lot of credit
to be deserved by the governor.
I mean, he took
some chances here
in terms of what was being told
to him from, you know,
the national media
versus what he decided to do
on the basis of the information
he had and that move
to make monoclonal antibodies
available to people,
not just that they got sick,
but even if they've
been exposed to it,
I think saved a lot of lives
and kept a lot of people out
of hospitals, it really did.
And I know that firsthand from
people that went through it.
I think that was a major
move, and an important one.
And why other states
didn't follow suit?
You know, I don't know.
I can tell you that why we
got into kind of involved
in it at that point is which,
when the federal government
under Joe Biden realized Florida
is making us look bad,
and so, they decided we're
going to start rationing this.
We're gonna start making sure
that each state gets
a certain amount,
but they don't, you know,
even if they're not using it
a lot for them in essence,
a way to restrict
Florida's access to it.
And at least for
some of those drugs,
the state could directly
negotiate with a company.
But there are some other,
especially the newer
ones where you got to go
through the federal government.
And that's at the point
where we really got concerned
because, you know,
when the federal
government starts saying,
we're gonna start
rationing this,
what you realize is they're
doing it to punish Florida,
they're doing it to make sure
that Florida doesn't
continue to embarrass them
by making this an effective
way to pursue this.
But, yeah, you know,
look, ultimately,
it's not just about
comparing us to other states.
I mean, you don't want
anybody to die or get sick,
but life is about the
management of risks.
There's benefits,
there's rewards,
and there's risks associated
to virtually
everything we'll do.
At some point today, you and I
and others will get in the
car and drive somewhere,
and there's real risk
involved in that.
And maybe more here than
other places, right.
But, there's risk
involved in it.
But, there are
things you just have
to be able to do in life.
And, in order to live.
And I think once you
make public policy
from that perspective,
it allows you to make
decisions like that.
- Where are you at with
using the levers of power
at this point, when
it comes to, you know,
there's still a lot of kids
in masks in schools here,
not all the schools,
it's a little unclear
to me if that's left
to the counties at this
point, or the mayors,
or there's obviously some
level of school choice
and private, public
school, all of that,
what do you think
should be happening?
Are you trying to push
one way or another
or where you at?
- Yeah, you know,
ultimately in my view,
I think one of the things
that this pandemic revealed
is the importance
of local government
and local control to
make those decisions.
And so, right now
at the state level,
schools are being told you
can't have a mask mandate.
So as an example,
the public schools here at
Miami-Dade have a mask mandate
for employees, but
not for the kids.
And there's a lot of reasons
that private schools can make
their own decisions, right.
So I have one kid who was
in a public charter school
and they don't have
a mask mandate,
I have my oldest son
is in a public private Catholic
high school, and they do.
But I can tell you a
couple of things about it.
The first is that, again,
it's a risk and reward
balancing prospect,
let me be frank, right.
The way these kids wear
the masks on, you know,
12 to 20 hour basis whenever
we're around the school,
isn't exactly, you know,
the way they're
supposed to wear them,
if they're even effective
at all, in that sense.
So that's the reality.
So you start thinking
there's okay,
they're not gonna wear the mask
the way they're
supposed to anyway,
all we're doing is creating
an additional irritant
in their educational setting.
And so, you hope there's
some common sense
into how that's enforced.
And then I think when you talk
about this Omicron variant,
it ultimately isn't, I mean,
if you talk to
people who will speak
to you honestly about it,
the banks aren't
gonna stop this,
this is a highly
infectious variant.
Luckily it's not as severe,
but it is highly infectious.
And there are just things
that aren't gonna
work against it.
And so, my view of it is,
I leave it to the states
and the school boards
to make those decisions,
but I would hope they
would make those decisions
with the best interests
of the kids in mind.
I'm much more worried
about them not learning how
to read and write than I am
about them not wearing the
mask exactly right, you know,
with the thing notched
over their nose.
And, especially since
they're not gonna wear
it right anyway,
and the masks most
of the kids are using
aren't even effective
against the old barrier,
not to mention Omicron.
- Yeah.
Well, that's a perfect way
to tie up the whole
Florida portion.
So I want to move a little
bit towards national politics
and what's going on
right now at the moment.
So in these last couple of days,
obviously we saw the
stalemate in the Senate
about the voting rights act.
You're gonna call me crazy,
I believe you have to have an ID
or you should have
an ID to vote.
The Democrats apparently,
don't believe that,
and if you believe
it, you're racist.
Now there's this fight
over the filibuster.
You mentioned a few minutes ago
that there used to sort
of be the same liberals
that you could debate
these ideas with,
is there anyone left over there?
I mean, I suspect
you'd probably think
Joe Manchin's pretty
decent at the moment,
but I mean, when you hear
them with these crazy policies
where we're gonna
have illegal voting
and you don't have to
have an ID to vote,
but you also have to
have a vaccine card
to walk into McDonald's.
I mean, do you get behind
closed doors with these guys
and go, what are you doing?
- Yeah, look, I think there's
more than just Joe Manchin
and Kyrsten Sinema
that they don't want
to get rid of the filibuster
and think some of these ideas
go beyond their comfort level.
But if you watch what's happened
to Joe Manchin and Kyrsten
Sinema when they stepped out,
there's a lot of people that
are saying, you know what,
I'm just gonna vote with a pack
and sort of keep my head down
and it's not gonna pass anyway,
thank God for Kyrsten
Sinema and Joe Manchin.
And so, these are people
that are voting yes,
but hoping for no.
And the fact that two people
are willing to step out
and do it kind of gave them
the result they wanted,
but these guys don't, they
don't want to be singled out.
They don't want donors
threatening them with primaries,
they're, scared.
And so, not saying
that's true of everybody,
but yeah, there are Democrats
that view this as kind of crazy,
but they got to say it
because their base has
become radicalized.
The people that knock on
doors and make phone calls
and that they need to
mobilize for election day
are demanding whatever the
pet issue of the moment is.
And there are far
outside the mainstream,
but if they take those people
on, they may not be back
and they certainly don't want
the headache associated with it.
And so, I think as
much as anything else,
the threats against Kyrsten
Sinema and Joe Manchin
that you've seen, is not so much
about Kyrsten Sinema
and Joe Manchin,
it's a message to
the other senators
and other members of
Congress who may be thinking
about stepping out of line,
that this is what awaits you,
this is what lies ahead for
you, if you step out of line.
So just be quiet and do
what we tell you to do.
And that's what I'd describe it.
- Are you surprised that the
leadership folded kind of
as quickly as it did?
Because I'm sure you saw it,
you may have been in
the chamber at the time.
Tom Cotton did a
really spectacular job
of repeating a speech
that Chuck Schumer gave
about the filibuster.
I think it was from, you
know, five or eight years ago,
something like that.
And then he announced
at the end, by the way,
that was Chuck Schumer,
that wasn't my speech.
And it's like,
I don't think Chuck was
truly this radically left
and even Nancy Pelosi
in San Francisco,
like obviously she
had some of that,
but I don't think she
was totally like this.
Are you surprised
that they folded,
not just the guys
that are watching out
for their back and just
want to get reelected,
but that the leadership
just all went in.
- On the filibuster?
- Well, on the filibuster
and that they're following just,
they're sort of far left
on all of this stuff.
- I'm not actually surprised.
And I'll tell you why.
So, they have all, here's what,
they've got a 50/50 Senate,
a very narrow
majority in the house,
but their base thinks
they have a mandate
to like transform radically
transform America.
And so they're getting
all this pressure about,
get this stuff done and
you go back then and say,
well, we can't, we
don't have 60 votes.
And then the base says to them,
well then, get rid of
the 60 vote thing, okay.
'Cause it's standing in the way
of our agenda and get it done.
And if you don't get it done
and that means
you're not with us.
And so, after a while
they start beating on,
you still look at this
fake voting rights thing.
It's just the issue they picked
to have a filibuster fight over,
but they were prepared to
do it over the debt ceiling.
And they were at
some point talking
about doing it for immigration
reform, you name it,
and they would find the issue.
This is just the one they
figured we have the best chance
to make a straight
faced argument on,
even though it wasn't
a very good one.
And as holding on it,
I don't think Chuck Schumer
had a choice, I really don't.
I think Chuck Schumer
hadn't done this,
he was almost certainly
gonna be primary
in New York in his Senate race.
And I think he
thought about that
as he went through this cycle.
And I think that's true for
a lot of their leadership,
and a lot of the people that
changed their position on it.
At the end of the day, yes,
they're in the leadership,
but they need to win elections,
and stay in that leadership.
And in that case,
the case in New York,
it means the Democratic primary
where he most
definitely does not want
to take on a far left
primary challenger
that could beat him,
that could beat him.
And so, he's trying
to avoid that.
And I think it was
pretty clear to him
that he didn't do this,
that was what's gonna
to happen to him.
- Yeah.
And there were even rumors
that AOC might be that person.
Just to give the devil his due.
I mean, was there anything
in the voting rights act
that you thought was legit,
or do you think the
entire thing was designed
for all the mail in ballots,
all the no ID stuff,
all the illegals, like
was it all designed just
to keep them in power forever
or was there anything in there?
I mean, is there
anyone in America today
that wants to vote
that can't vote
for a legitimate reason
or for any illegitimate
reason, as you say?
- I don't think it's ever,
look, I can't speak for
every state in the union
about exactly what their
voting rights and laws are,
but there are
things in that bill
that are mandated that
Florida already does.
We already have early
voting here, okay.
We have a 14-day period of
13-day period of early voting.
And then you've got, anybody
can vote by mail in Florida.
You don't have to prove
that you're gonna be out
of town or whatever.
And then you got election day
where you can go
to your precinct
and from 7:00 am to 7:00 pm
as long as you're in
line before 7:00 pm,
you can vote that way.
So it's never been easier.
But, when I first ran
for office in 2010,
there was still, you know,
early voting was at one
point in this state limited.
They didn't even exist
20 years ago, right.
It didn't, when I first voted
in my first election, 1989,
there was no early voting.
If you wanted to vote absentee,
you had to write a letter
saying I'm gonna be out of town
or having surgery or
whatever it is on that day.
And so, I don't think
it's ever been easier
to either register or
to vote in Florida.
So, it's not, for me, the
big problem is first of all,
there is no concerted effort
to deny access to the ballot,
to anyone in America.
Some of those ideas that
are talking about, okay,
you know, ballot harvesting,
allowing people to go out
and just grab
ballots and put them,
we had a huge crisis about
that here in Florida.
And by the way,
it was in a lot of times in
Republican primary races,
where were these
people you would hire
and they would go out
and they would collect
the 150, 200 ballots.
And, it just led to all
sorts of shenanigans.
Look, we had a mayor's
race in Miami overturned
by a judge a year
after the election,
because there was so
much massive fraud
on the absentee ballot front.
A lot of it driven
by ballot harvesting.
And so, we banned those
practices here in Florida.
And the biggest challenge,
the biggest problem I had
is this sort of the
federal government
is going to take over elections,
which is what this is,
is a huge problem for me
big, big problem.
Because you've now
centralized election authority
in America and now it's at the
whim of whoever's in power.
- Well, how worried are you that
that is the future of America?
I mean, my main concern
as a new Floridian
is that we're gonna keep
doing things right here,
we're gonna keep electing
the right officials,
our businesses are
going to thrive,
people are going to
be out and about,
but the federal government
simply will not let us alone.
It's sort of to
your point earlier
about Florida did it right
with monoclonal treatment.
So what was the federal
government response?
Oh, we're gonna push tamper down
on who can get it and
when they can get it.
So what do we do here
to make sure that
that sort of ever-growing
federal government
doesn't do what?
I can't even imagine
what they could do,
but I know there's
stuff they can do.
- Yeah.
You know, that's a great
question to a Senator
because if you look at
the design of the Senate,
the Senate was designed
to represent the states,
to be the voice of state.
That's why every state
gets two of them.
Small states get two of them,
big states to get two of them.
And part of our job is to
keep that balance in place
between the federal
and state government,
between the different
levels of government.
And, oftentimes
people think it's not,
because I'm against
the federal government
doing something on an issue,
doesn't mean the issue
is not important,
I just think the
local government
or the state government
would do a better job
of dealing with it than the
federal government would.
It's actually a
fascinating question.
If you go back to 1500,
from the year 1500 forward,
and you look at the rise
and fall of great powers,
there are a lot of reasons
why great powers fall.
But one of the thing many
of those great
powers had in common
is they centralized
government control.
And what that meant is that
entrepreneurial spirit,
that competition to see
who had better ideas,
that creativity and innovation
that you would see when power
is decentralized, they
lost that, they lost it.
And the places that are a
little bit more flights,
one of the key reasons
why Europe surpassed the,
the Asia-Pacific region
in global leadership,
because they didn't have a
strong central government
that sort of quashed that.
So there's historical
reasons for it.
I think it's true with our,
I think it's also aligned
with our constitution
and look at every innovation
in public education America
over the last 20 years,
they've all been driven
by state initiatives
like school choice and
things of that nature.
They've all been driven
by at the state level
because states want
to have a better education
system than other states
so that people will
move their businesses
and their families there.
And so, I'm gonna work very hard
to continue to make sure
that the Senate stands
in the way of any effort
to have federal takeovers
and big public policy
issues of that type.
- So speaking of
federal takeovers,
Biden obviously gave
this big press conference
in the last couple of days.
From where I'm sitting.
I mean, the guy is not the
Joe Biden of 10 years ago.
I think that's a pretty deep
underestimation actually.
Do you think he's really
running the show at this point?
I mean, he constantly,
at the end of these press
conferences, he constantly says,
oh, I'm not allowed to say that,
or they don't want
me to say this,
or they brush him off or
he sits there awkwardly
as people yell questions
and he doesn't answer.
I mean, what do you
think is going on here?
- Yeah.
I mean, I don't know Joe
Biden very well personally.
I never served with
him in the Senate.
I did interact with him
when he was vice-president
and obviously, you
know, the person
that's there today is
not the same person.
And I'm in no
position to speculate
as to what has changed,
but it's just not.
And that said, I mean,
he has a long history
of sort of saying things
that are silly and gas-prone,
we know that, I mean, that's
a well understood dynamic.
I think the Obama
administration understood
that about him as well,
and tried to protect
him from himself
and certainly administration
from some of those things.
Well I think it really
becomes relevant,
look, I'm not one of
these people that,
because someone
misstates a word,
it doesn't perfectly
phrase something,
something goes crazy,
I'll look at what they
said, and I'm gonna go
that's silly sort of theatrics
- I talk to the camera
for a living, I'm with ya,
I'm with ya.
- Yeah.
(Marco chuckles)
So, I'm not big on
that kind of stuff,
but I do think it's
relevant, okay.
When you watch this and you
see a consistent pattern
of saying things, you know,
in the big speech he gave in
Georgia a couple of weeks ago,
he talked about when
he had been arrested,
it's been well-documented,
that he's never been arrested
and the civil rights protest.
And I think if Vladimir Putin
or the Chinese leadership
of the communist party,
you're watching that and saying,
there's something
wrong with this guy.
I mean, I think there are
things we can get away with
as long as that guy is there.
And the fact that they
would have the same question
that you have, who's
actually running the place?
Who's actually
making the decisions?
Is a dangerous thing
for the country.
I mean, they had
to spend basically
the last 24 hours
cleaning up what he said
about Ukraine and, you know,
a partial invasion
versus a full invasion
that's just one element of
something he said on that day.
The other is, he kinda
alluded, said, well,
maybe a midterms aren't
gonna be legitimate,
they had to clean
that up as well.
So, you know, he's
not the same person,
I don't know who's
running the show.
I'm in no position to
speculate about that,
but I can tell you,
they spent a lot of time having
to sort of clean up
the things he says
and our adversaries noticed it.
- Yeah, for sure.
I mean, look, we've
already talked
about the election
stuff so we can let part
of what he said go
because it's sorta,
(Dave chuckles)
it's basically like
they spent four years
under Trump
questioning elections.
Now we can't, now
they're preparing us
to question elections
when they get, you know,
she'll act at the
end of this year.
But on the Putin-Ukraine stuff,
I thought that was one
of the worst few minutes
a president has had
at least in my lifetime.
But basically just saying,
you can kind of
do what you want.
We don't really know.
And, you pretty much know
we're not gonna do anything.
I mean, what happened
to some level
of deterrence or a red line
perhaps or something like that?
- Yeah.
Look, I mean, the
most important thing
is you have to explain to
people why that even matters.
That's a very legitimate point
'cause I think
Americans are very wary
of sort of engaging us in
conflicts around the world.
So let me be frank.
I mean, there's not
gonna be American troops
in Ukraine taking on
a Russian invasion
because you can't really
have a conventional war
between two nuclear powers.
And it's too risky,
it has the real danger
of escalating and the
battlefield into something,
it's just not, that's not
what anybody's talking about.
I think what is important
is Vladimir Putin
has to assist there
and we've got to do
everything possible
so that he calculates that
the price of doing this
is higher than the benefits
he's gonna gain from it.
And that's not an
easy thing to do
because the guy's convinced
that we're gonna make
Ukraine a member of NATO,
there are gonna be
American missile
and troops there at some
point, right on his border.
And so, we've gotta change,
that's how high the
risk is for him.
We've gotta change the
reward pattern on it.
I think part of
that is economic.
I think part of it
is you're starting
to hear people say
it as the reality,
that Ukrainians aren't
gonna welcome these guys
and say, oh thank you for
taking over our country.
I mean, they're gonna face
a protracted insurgency
of Ukrainian, non-Americans
of Ukrainians, you know,
I don't know what
significant percentage
of that population has a history
or training or background
in military service.
And you're gonna have, you know,
years and years and years of
people taking shots at you.
And I think this country
as much as any understands
that when you invade a country,
you now have to
govern and occupy it.
And the people there
aren't that happy,
they make life
miserable for you.
It's really, it's gonna bleed
and drain the
Russian government.
And Vladimir Putin is
gonna have to explain
to Russian moms why their
sons are coming home in boxes
because they took over a
place that doesn't want em.
And those risks have to
be made clear up front
in addition to the economic
pain and suffering.
I believe Vladimir Putin
is gonna do something.
I think probably the
highest probability
is he moves straight into KIA,
goes right after KIA
decapitates the government,
he's already setting
up the pretext for it.
And we didn't need to make
sure that if he does it,
he pays a tremendous
price 'cause it's
not just about Putin.
This matters because if
he can get away with it,
China says, well, that's
the model for Taiwan.
And, maybe North Korea says,
that's the model for us
to take over the
entire peninsula
and who knows who else is
thinking about things like this.
- Is that our biggest
problem outside of our border
is that if we don't do
anything, nobody else will?
And sort of after 20 years
of failed nation building
like the American
people, as he said,
people don't want,
they certainly don't
want a ground war,
I don't think they
want any sort of war,
I don't want a war, I
don't want to nation build,
but I understand we do have
a unique place in the world.
And if we're not the ones
kinda saying bad guys,
you can't always do
whatever you want to do.
It's like, then
all bets are off.
- Yeah.
Look, I mean, if you're
gonna be a country
as big and as powerful with an
economy, as advanced as ours,
then what happens around the
world is gonna matter to you
because you're
sourcing products,
you're sourcing raw material,
energy, trade, commerce
with all over the world.
And so, you need
there to be stability.
The one thing you can never
allow happen for example,
is let's say China comes
to dominate the
Asia-Pacific region
and so, suddenly we can't trade,
We've just lost all
those countries in Asia
that we sell things to
and buy things from.
We have to deal with
China and they decide what
to sell or buy from us.
So a lot of that
is really domestic.
Like we have to have an
industrial capability
in this country.
We have to have the ability,
you cannot be a great power
if you're not an
industrial power.
I don't care what
people tell you.
You can't just be the place
that invents things on paper,
and then ships it off for
someone else to make it,
eventually the people making
these things are the people
that will invent them.
And not to mention
the national security
ramifications of it.
So, number one,
we have to be in
industrial power.
Number two, we have to make sure
that we don't live in a world
in which a great power
dominates a region.
And basically we have
no access to people
that want to trade
in commerce with us.
That said, that
has to be balanced
against the notion
of overextension.
There are a lot of bad things
that happen in the world.
We need to speak about
it and do what we can,
but most of them do not have
an American military solution,
nor should they, in terms
of us getting involved
and overextending ourselves.
Our number one priority must
always be the national interest
of our country and
protecting it from threats,
both at home and our
interests around the world.
And it's a balance
that they have
to pull off in public policy.
But to your greater point
about no one else will do it,
I think a lot of
times what happens is
if America isn't involved,
then some people
will get involved,
but they're gonna
get involved in ways
that may not necessarily
further our national interests.
The withdrawal from
Afghanistan, for example,
has led a lot of countries
in the middle of it
to increasingly turn
to China and Russia,
as their defense
partner preference.
And that's concerning
because that could mean
for the future of
American economic
prosperity and security.
- Do you think some of
this is sorta by design?
Like when you see the
way a guy like say,
Bill de Blasio kind of
wrecked New York city,
which is just an
absolute disaster,
a place that I lived
most of my adult life
before moving to LA, you
know, people are like,
oh, you know, this
is an accident.
There're like, these policies,
he didn't realize
what was gonna happen,
but he just gave a speech a
couple days ago where it's like,
oh no, this was great,
it's all great here.
And I feel the sorta
similar way with Biden.
It's like, I don't know
that he really thinks
things aren't going well.
Now you look at the shelves
and you look at people's
jobs and everything else,
and you clearly realize
the price of gas,
the price of food, et cetera,
you realize things aren't.
But do you think some of
it is actually by design
that it's a feature not a
bug in the way they govern.
- Both, I think it's
the natural consequences
of these decisions
that always lead to disaster.
But I think they're
not necessarily overly
troubled by them.
Inflation is a great example.
Inflation, if you believe
that you want
Marxism and socialism
and you want the government to
control more of our economy,
then inflation is
necessarily a bad thing
because the way you view it
as the more expensive
life gets, right,
the harder it is
to afford things,
to get childcare,
the harder, the more expensive
it is to go to school,
the more people are going
to be open to the argument
that these things cost too much.
The only way you're
gonna be able
to have it is that the
government provides it for you.
And so, once the
government begin there,
the government
doesn't just take over
early childhood
education, it decides,
when it takes it over,
what's being taught and
who gets to teach it.
It doesn't just take
over higher education.
It decides what you have to
teach and who gets to go.
It doesn't just take over.
When it sends you the cheque
in the mail every
month, you know,
it doesn't just decide how much
money you have in the bank.
It makes you dependent on
that program continuing
and having to increase
taxes on other people
in order for the money
to be there, to do that.
So in many ways, I think
this inflation is an example
and even a supply
shortages create a scenario
in which people they think,
or become more open,
they're becoming
dependent on government
to fill in their needs because
the economy can't do it
only government can do it.
And that's the fundamental
argument they're making, right.
Is that, these are
important things in life,
private economy
cannot provide it for,
cannot provide you this
security, only government can.
But that always
comes at the price
of your freedom and liberty,
both economic and personal.
- Yeah.
And that's what I mean
about feature, not a bug.
It's like a guy like de Blasio,
he wrecked New York city,
but in his view, it's like, oh,
but the government's
doing more now.
So thus,
- Yeah.
- This is good.
And I think that that's
sorta what's going
on all over the place.
So to that point, obviously
there's midterms come in,
you know, everybody's talking
about some big red
wave or something.
I'm pretty sure we're gonna
be safe here in Florida.
Do you, by the way, do you
say Florida or Florida?
I'm a New Yorker originally.
So I say, Florida,
you say everyone's else
saying Florida here,
but I also say orange
juice, not orange juice.
So I'm-
- No, no, no, no
one's ever, I mean,
I've heard about
Nevada and Nevada,
but I've never had a
Florida and Florida.
I don't know, I say Florida.
I don't know.
- You say Florida,
I say Florida.
People are telling
me it's in New York
that we say, Florida, we say
orange instead of orange,
but, what do you think
is going to happen
in this midterm situation?
I mean, do you think we
can actually capture?
I mean, we, I never would
have said we before,
but I think it's we at
this point, you know,
get the house back.
It sounds like the Senate
is gonna do pretty well.
What do you sense?
- Well, the easiest
way to lose at anything
is to think is to act
like you're winning.
So I think that's the first
thing we have to keep in mind.
The second is, I mean, these
guys raised a lot of money
as an example, right.
Chuck Schumer went out and
handpicked the Val Demings,
the Congresswoman from central
Florida was just a puppet
of Nancy Pelosi and said,
that's who I want to be
our candidate in Florida.
And she's raising $10 million
a quarter or more online,
just sending out an email.
So, they're gonna raise that
kind of money for candidates.
I mean, every Senate Republican
incumbent was outraised
in 2020 and in 2018.
So we can't overlook the fact
that these people are
gonna outraise us.
And we're also not gonna
get any benefit from media,
as a perfect example, okay.
I was ranked the most
effective Republican Senator
by the Vanderbilt
University of Virginia,
a program that looks
at the effectiveness
of members of Congress
and other group.
Again, nonpartisan ranked
me the second, number two
in leadership score,
passed a bunch of
really meaningful bills,
not the least of
which was the creation
of the paycheck
protection program
that literally saved millions
of small business
jobs in this country.
You wouldn't know that.
I mean, we could go to
a couple of weeks ago,
it was my work and having
to blow up the defense bill
that forced Nancy Pelosi
in the house to pass a
bill that banned the import
of products made by
Uyghurs slave labors.
None of that stuff
is reported on,
the media is a real
challenge for us
'cause they're not gonna report
on our accomplishments
or accurately.
In many cases, they put
out what we're working on
or what our position
is on these issues.
And so, I wouldn't take
that for granted either.
And so, these guys are
gonna have more money
and they're gonna have the
benefit of mainstream media.
So we're going to
have to work real hard
to make sure that our
base knows what's going on
and that people
turn out and vote,
do I feel good about the
direction of Florida?
Do I feel good about the fact
that people are realizing
Joe Biden is a disaster?
Absolutely, but the election
isn't today, it's in November,
we've got a long ways to
go between now and then.
And we've gotta make sure
that people keep learning,
not just about what
they're doing wrong,
but what we're gonna do right
if they give us the
chance to be in a position
of control in the
Senate and house.
- So putting aside politics
as we get close to wrap here,
you know, we've talked a
couple of times before,
and I know all about your
family's story of coming here
and your dad washing
dishes and the whole thing.
And then you rise
to become a Senator.
It's exactly what the
American story is.
Are you still hopeful
for that story?
Because so much of what
we hear is designed
at destroying that story,
that the whole purpose
of this country was
based on systemic racism.
That's the founding principle.
I mean, all the woke nonsense,
when you get through all that,
are you still hopeful
that the dream
that your parents came here
with is still available
to other people and that we
can actually strengthen them?
- Yeah, I am.
In fact, I'm not just
hopeful about it.
I think that's our
destiny as a country,
but we're constantly
reinventing ourselves.
And when you reinvent yourself
and I mean that
in a positive way,
reinvigorate yourself
really is the term.
It gets messy and
conflicted, you know,
in every generation,
every 30, 40 years,
we have some group of people
that rise in politics and say,
you know, this America thing,
isn't actually that good.
It isn't as good as
people make it out to be.
We really need to change.
We really can't continue to
do these sorts of things.
And it gets traction
for a little while
because they take advantage
of some peculiarity
of the moment.
But eventually what happens
is that the overwhelming
majority of Americans,
including people that don't
agree on a lot of issues, right.
People may not agree
on what the tax rates
should be or whatever,
but they generally
agree on one thing.
And that is, look guys,
what we have is pretty good.
I wouldn't rather
be anybody else.
And we can't walk
away from the things
that made it that way and
we've got to build on that.
And I think that's what you
see that's happening right now.
Okay, I think that's what
you see happening right now.
There are a lot of
people out there
that voted for Joe Biden,
maybe he didn't
like Donald Trump,
maybe they've never
voted for a Republican,
but they don't
understand why their kids
are being pulled
out of school, okay.
They got a four-year-old,
they're on their fifth,
10 day quarantine,
even though their child
is tested negative
because some kid in class
and nobody, you know,
and he tested positive
and no one seems
to care or listening to them.
Now, there are people
that are saying, look,
my kid has really not been
in a stable learning
environment for two years,
how are we gonna make that up?
But what's that gonna mean down
the road and in the feature?
There are small business owners,
many of them maybe
are liberal Democrats,
but they're like, I
can't hire anybody.
And if I hire someone,
they hire them on Monday,
Thursday, they just
stopped showing up
and all my products cost more
and I can't pass it
through to the consumer.
So, there's an awakening
going on in this country
about the consequences
of these policies.
And sometimes it's
messy and it's loud,
but, I would say this, who
would I trade places with?
Who would you trade places with?
There's no country in the world
that I looked at and I say,
I wish I were them instead
of us, and we build on that.
So yes, the raw elements,
there's nothing,
the American people
are, would be fine.
It's our government,
that's broken.
It's a people making decisions
at the highest levels
of corporate America
that are broken, not our people.
And, it's gonna take some time
to work its way
through to the top.
- All right, Senator,
one more for you on
that note, actually.
So as Mayor Suarez
down here in Miami said
in that famous tweet, I
believe it was to Keith Rabois
when he was considering
moving to Florida.
Mayor Suarez says,
what can I do to help?
Well, hey, I'm a
new Floridian man.
What can I do to
help you right here?
And by me, I mean, literally me,
but I mean anyone watching this
and especially anyone
that lives right here.
- Well, at the-
- What can we do to help?
- I mean, at the expense
of sounding shameless,
as I've just pointed out,
I mean, I've got an
opponent running against me.
That's outraising
me online, you know,
donors from all over
the country, honestly.
He's MSNBC, Binge-watchers
that are sending
stuff in the mail.
So, I just ask
people if they can
to go on marcorubio.com,
marcorubio.com
and give whatever you can,
because I need that help
to get our word out
and our message out.
And I think beyond that,
it's just to continue to be
a platform like you've done,
where people can speak truth,
where people can hear from the
people, not just an office,
but people that are in
the periphery of politics,
but who have opinions
on these issues.
And it's become harder than ever
to have these sort of
long form conversations
and nuanced conversations.
So people can hear what
we actually stand for
and have debate.
Maybe there's a disagreement
about people's stand for,
nowadays, it's harder than
ever, I mean, it really is.
I mean, you just can't
get a message out anymore,
on a legacy media and
it's platforms like this
that are protecting
the First Amendment
and making that possible.
So, keep doing what you're
doing with our Florida flare,
now that you're down
here and talking
about what really is
happening down here.
And hopefully that'll
inspire people
across the country
to elect the people
and follow the direction
that we've followed here.
- Well, Senator I'm pretty
sure, not totally sure,
I'm pretty sure I could
speak for all of my staff
that you have at
least eight new votes
(Marco chuckles)
- In Florida
- Good.
- that have just moved here
and we're going to see
what else we can do.
It was a pleasure
talking to you as always.
I appreciate the time.
- Hey, thanks for having
me on, welcome to Florida.
- Thanks.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics, instead
of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.